So
We are here in the last session of the day
in the states
and we are going to talk about a
subject that I think it was very recurring
during the whole year for you guys. For
me it was.
We are going to talk about agentic
assistance.
But
energetic system is not a
simple solution that requires
a knowledge basis, a
model, and we would
simply
answer questions.
We are thinking about a more sophisticated
system.
Think about an approach where we are
treating our agenttic system
like a microservices architecture.
So in this session we are going to talk
about agent core.
My name is Marilia Brito. I'm a senior
technical instructor and leader
of the instructors in Brazil, Sao
Paulo.
So this is our agenda. We're
going to check every single component
of this modular architecture
that Agent Core has.
But
let's start simple, right?
First, we have the elements
to build
this gigantic system.
We have the goals and instructions, so
we have to perform something in this system.
And also the tools.
The tools are able to reach internal
and external systems.
The tool can be a little bit of function,
why not? Or it can be an external
API as well. It depends on
our business necessities.
We have also here
an important thing of a
system, of any system,
the observability.
We must understand how
our components are working
individually and together
and how the agency is behaving.
So
what's happening during the
reasoning loops?
What's happening when we call a
different tool?
Is this the correct tool?
So we are only going to know about it
if we have monitoring, OK.
But
Let me ask you a question.
How many of you built an agentic
system working with any, it
doesn't matter the framework, with any framework
from end to end in
this last year?
Oh,
We have a few a few people over here,
but I have a different question right
now. Was it easy?
To manage the components,
was it or not?
No,
it's not easy
because
in this microservice architecture,
well, the premises is simple. We
have a distributed system,
so we have many components to
take to take care
and sometimes we don't have the
purpose-built solution
to work with this,
so.
We must think about infrastructure.
We must think about.
We must think about
maybe more than one model
for a specific purpose.
And sometimes people tend to think
that I'm going to work with
the biggest model that
Ever existed
with billions of parameters and
this will be enough for me, but actually
this doesn't matter. What matters is
to structure your architecture with
the modular components that will
be configured according to your
needs. So that's why we are going to
talk about Agent Core.
Agentco is the managed and
purpose-built service focused on
bringing all the magic that we
have in identity system
to a place where we are going to
think about this modular architecture
piece by piece, configuring
according to our needs
and
Firstly, we can think that, oh,
but this is too much complexity.
No, it's much simpler
than you can, you are thinking.
On Agent's car,
we have these modules.
So the first module, the runtime,
will take care about the execution
environment and working with isolated
sessions.
After that,
we have the agent's core
gateway. The gateway will
expose the tools, even if
the tools are internal.
But
we don't want to provide
a full access to every
single tool,
so we have the agent's core identity
to take care about the authentication
and the authorization
of the actions that the
agent is going to perform.
Observability because we said that monitoring
is very important and it is.
And also
memory, so we can work
with context.
And now we are going to explore
every single component
here.
And also on Monday,
there was a few launches about
Agent Core,
and I tried to incorporate a
little bit of this,
of the launches in this presentation.
OK, I woke up today at 5:30
to insert this news, so
I hope you enjoy it.
Let's start with run time.
The run time is the component
where the
The reasoning loop
will occur.
So here we have a standardized
execution environment that
is isolated for each session.
So one session is not able to
check the other session,
um,
even using the same agent,
OK.
And the magical thing
about the run time
is that,
OK, I know everybody
has their, has their favorite
model.
Everybody has their favorite
framework, and it's OK. I have
mine too,
but for a runtime
it doesn't matter.
You can choose whatever open source framework
you want. So if you want to work with
strengths, it's OK. Crew
AI, Leama Index, Long chain.
It will,
it will work in the same way.
You can also bring models from Amazon
Bedrock, Amazonage maker AI,
and external models.
So.
We have.
We have a clear use case dependency
here and we have a model
and framework
flexibility
as well,
so it doesn't matter if you have a simple
workflow. I just have
to check a knowledge base,
a calculation tool, and that's
it.
Run time can handle this.
I have to work with 100
tools.
I have to access 30
different knowledge bases. It's
OK. It will work at the same
time. How
can we configure
the runtime?
First, for our recipe, we need
the model and also the framework.
After that,
we have the runtime decorator,
and the runtime decorator defines
how the runtime.
how the run time should execute
the agent
and the tools.
The second element here is the identity
configuration,
and the identity configuration will
be part of a different model that
we are going to see next,
but it will define
authorization here.
So which actions are
we going to be able to perform in the
session?
And the observability configuration.
So
which metrics are we going to
use to check our system
uh configability and also
if it is performing in the way that we are
expecting. We
are going to package this
using Docker.
And after that, the docker image
will be registered in the
ECR in the Elastic container
registry.
After that,
we are going to launch
our execution environment. So
when there is a need to call an agent,
the execution environment will be launched,
and we have the runtime agent,
so where the reasoning is going to happen
and the runtime end point.
We have a different element that we are going to talk
about. The name is gateway, but
this is how the gateway is going to
connect
to the runtime,
OK?
But
Let's pretend that we already
started our run time. Let's talk
about the life cycle.
In the life cycle of the run time
first.
The session is activist. So we are performing
actions.
We are using tools,
we are performing reasoning, we are checking the
knowledge bases,
the, the system is observing,
OK?
So we are working with something
here. But after
a task
is finished,
The session will turn to an
idle stage.
And the idle stage
for the fall,
it stays up to
15 minutes, but idle, it's OK,
it's waiting for a new task.
But if nothing happens in
these 15 minutes,
the session will be terminated.
But
what if 15 minutes
of waiting is not enough for us?
We want to maintain the environment
warm.
We don't want to start a cold
session.
So in this case,
we can extend the maximum session
duration for up to 8
hours, OK. After 8 hours,
the runtime environment will
be terminated.
OK?
So, let's proceed to
the identity model.
The identity model
will take care about the authorization
and authentication,
and there are
333 different ways
that we can work with this component.
So
we can use IAM.
We can use also Amazon Cognito
or an external provider
like Octa,
Microsoft, Intra ID.
So in this case, it's a little
bit different how we are going to work
with tokens. Yes,
there are tokens involved.
The identity
We work with two
separated sessions, the inbound
and outbound, and we can check
that the inbound is happening,
the authorization is happening
before the solicitation reaches
the agent.
So first of all,
any user, because usually
we are working with users, right?
Users are going to use these agents
to
respond, to have an answer about about
something. So in this case,
first,
The session
must be authorized on the
inbound using IAM
or using the OAuf
for an external provider.
After
everything is approved.
The agent is going to start
to check the input,
so the instructions that we sent,
uh, decompose into steps,
and each step is going to be sent
to a different tool.
If the tool is internal,
so a little bit of function, for
instance,
we are going to use the IAM,
the IAM signed before to
authorize this kind of
operation. But what if the
tool is external?
In this case,
we are going to use uh
the OAuf.
So we are trying to reach an external
system, it's OK, we are going to
use the OALF.
But what actually
happened in the outbound?
Are we going to use the same tokens that
we received in the inbound?
No, The
first token
that is that will be stored
in
the next component that we are going to check
will be swapped
like a trusted
relationship.
So if you were able to
access the agent,
I'm going to use your token,
swap for a new token
to authorize this external
external access.
But in cases that
We started the inbound
with IAM or OAuf,
and in the second part
in the outbound, we are going to use a
different kind of authentication.
What is going to happen? It, it's pretty similar,
but the token is not renewed, it
is not swapped. In this case,
the first token will be used to
fetch.
The second token.
So that's how we can
access these external tools.
The next component is the gateway.
So how are we going to expose
the tools?
Well,
we can expose the tools, so RIO
APIs, Lambda functions,
or even servers
using the gateway.
And
there is a few strategies that we
can adopt
to,
to better, to improve
how these tools are going to be
uh used.
So not just by keywords, OK.
In this case, we can use also
the semantic search to
match the right tool.
So let's explore
the agent core gateway.
It started with the architecture
that we checked before.
So I have a user prompt
reaching the agent.
Uh, we already had
the in Baodo education before it,
and now
the gateway must provide the
access for the tools.
OK.
Take a look
in that secure talking vault.
This is pretty important.
Why are we talking about the identity
module?
I'm told that the toks are
stored somewhere.
So this is the A place where the
tokens will be stored.
We don't want to store the tokens
inside the runtime
because the run time we have plenty of things
happening over there.
We want to store this externally
so it makes sense to be
inside the gateway.
When we are working with the gateway,
first we have a session ID
that is provided by
the runtime.
And this session ID will
be binded
with a workload ID.
So what the what the agent
is going to perform here,
OK, we have these two ideas
that we are going to check after
in the observability module.
So in this case,
it's providing the safe access
um.
I'm not going to say it's the standard
practice to work with MCP
for external tools. You can use
lambda function as well
to access an external API,
but
I must say that MCP during
my customers' conversation is
the king of popularity,
right? So
here we have the access for the external
tools.
This is new.
This was launched Monday.
In the identity configuration,
yes, we have security over there.
We are checking
if someone can assume
accession.
Inside an agent and to start the runtime.
But with this new capability, the
policy and agent core that is still
in preview, OK, it's pretty fresh.
We can work with more
detail, more,
more granularity.
In our policies.
You can write the policy using
natural language, in this case in English,
OK,
but if you rather, you can
use the Cedar language
as well to structure this
policy.
So here
Um,
here I'm going to think about the
tools that are going to be accessed
by the
Through
the gateway.
OK.
If you want to know more
about these capabilities,
there is a blog post
from Danilo
Danilo Poncea or is Daniel, I think
it's Danilo Poncecia,
um.
And there is this one and 4
more launches.
OK, I don't have the QR code. I'm sorry,
but I think that you find very easily.
I have a quick demo
about the gateway.
So it's the coding
from a workshop
where we have the creation
of the gateway,
so providing the name
and the description.
I'm going to use a semantic.
Module so to find the correct tools,
in this case.
OK. After that, there is the
creation of the gateway.
And I'm going to use a
key. This is the end.
Amazon research name the protocol.
Now we are going to add the target
in the gateway.
So we have to pass the gateway ID,
the name of the target,
the target description.
A little bit of function in this case that I'm
going to use.
OK.
And for authentication, I'm working
with Cognito.
This is the architecture that we already checked
on the east light.
So we have lambda functions here
and we also have external.
But in this demo, I'm going to focus more on
the Lambda function.
OK. The gateway was
created.
And now we are going to add the targets.
So first we have a little bit of function
that we handle with restaurant
reservations.
And also a calculator.
A different function with a calculator.
But just to show that we can add
more tools.
So
up to 1000 tools per target,
I'm adding more calculators over
here. I'm
actually duplicated, but we are going to
interpret it as mortals.
OK.
And after that, we are going to print.
And show that the tools were added.
I swear it works.
Perfect. And then we are going to list
the tools.
And
It's done.
So up to 100 targets
per gateway and up to 1000
tools, OK.
Let's take a different model
now, the memory model.
It's very important to think about
the memory because we don't want to repeat
every single
word in every single interaction
with an agent. It's pretty boring,
right? It's like to
talk
with a goldfish.
So an agent without memory is like
a goldfish. It will forget
what you said 3 seconds before.
This is a little bit exaggerated, I know,
but it, it's
almost the same case.
So here,
we have a person asking about
how to switch apps
on her, on the phone.
We have the answers. So
what model are you using and the model?
OK, we have an answer how to switch
the apps.
2 days
before this,
how do I take a screenshot of my
phone? Oh, what's the mode?
We have to explain everything.
So we don't want to have this kind of
problem. Our customers are
not going to be happy
to repeat every single thing again.
There are 2 kinds,
actually, now there are 3
kinds of memory managing
on agent court.
The first one is the short-term
memory, so the memory that we
are going to use during a session.
OK.
So here we have 3
components.
So the first one, the events
are the records of a single
interaction with the user
and the agents, OK.
So,
we can have the two actions, we
can have the assistant and also
the user messages included here.
We can start this one by
one or in batches. It depends
on the volume of the
conversation. The actors,
so which users and which
agents are included in this
conversation. And
the session.
So, in which period
we had this conversation.
Here is a small example.
But it happened in the same day, so it's
not the same case that we are talking
about in the first slide of this component,
OK. Sorry.
So let's check now the long
term memory.
In the long-term memory, I'm going
to, I'm going to talk a little
bit about summary, user preference,
semantic,
but there is a new capability,
OK?
This new capability helps
the agent.
Actually help help the agent in the memory
to learn more about how
are you communicating
with your agent.
So. What's the
tone
that this customer is using?
What is, what are, what are the
subjects
that this customer is interested in?
What about the details
about the subject?
So in this case,
we are going to use
to collect
this kind of information for a better
experience,
OK? But let's check the
other components,
the user preference.
So here we, here we have a different
conversation. So I like
this this brand of headphones.
My company gives me 25%
for the item,
and I prefer white open
ear headphones.
White?
No, it gets dirty.
OK.
This conversation, this session is
stored in the memory
and now we have the preference of these
users. So it depends on the
context, it depends on the interactions
that you want to store.
If you have, uh,
if you're selling electronics, this
makes no sense.
OK.
So, we are storing the color,
the brand and the model.
Four days.
So 4 days after that in June
5th, I want,
I want new headphones. It's time
to change the old ones
and the agent will be smart enough to to
fetch the previous information
and include.
In this conversation, even with the 25%
of discount.
Semantic
Um
We are not going to store
every single sentence in any
case that we are checking here.
So in semantics, we are choosing,
not us, but the model is choosing
the most important information
of this conversation. So a
summary,
OK. This
person is pretty hard to
make this person happy,
right, so.
Now this person wants to return
the headphones that I bought last week
because
found $100 cheaper
elsewhere,
but our agent is pretty
smart, so we will help this customer
to pay less, so we'll refund
$100 in difference. I really
like this agent.
Summary
Well,
In this case,
We have just a summarization. I told you
that we don't have all the lines of a
chat,
just the preference or the semantics
or what is similar,
and here the summary.
The person broke the phones.
So now, I broke the phones,
um,
and now the agent is going to
happen maybe to fix it or maybe to
send the customer
for some kind of shop
that they can fix
this, these headphones,
OK? About
the memory
The default storage of the memory
is 7 days,
but you can store the memory up
to 1 year.
OK.
A lot of time.
Sometimes we don't remember what we said one year
ago, right?
Now let's check the browser.
The browser module, we are going
to use,
it's correct,
we are going to use when there is a need
to access a web interface,
so a website that we must
search for something.
So in this case,
we can use also the security
controls of the VPC.
We have um
a a micro VM
that we are going to work for this kind of
operations. Actually,
almost everything on Agent Core,
we are going to use a micro VM, but
it's services, so we don't have to
worry about
the size of the instance or
even the scalability configurations.
This is built in in the servicing.
But in this case we can control
the network level
security using the Amazon VPC.
So
What happens when we use the browser?
First,
there is the user. Oh, I want to
buy new shoes.
Me too. Send
this to the agent
and the agent will invoke the model,
but
the model is not responsible
to access
the site.
The browser is going to access
So in this case, we are going to use
a computer to call indicating
what, what actions need to be
performed in this browser.
So here it's pretty simple, it's pretty simple,
right? We are going to click using
the left button and we have also
the position
to click in the screen.
This will be translated to CDP
comments and we are going to use
the browser as a headless
browser,
so
similar to Selenium, but we're going to
use a Playwright
browser.
And then
we had a screenshot, and this was
returned to our customer.
But
I have this in more details.
How do we work
with the browser?
First, in this example,
We have a situation where
I asked to search
on Amazon for a MacBook.
List
The options and return
the description of the first
option. OK?
So first here we are starting
with the imports that are necessary,
OK, so the browser on Agent Core,
Jason and another different kinds
of imports,
but to open.
Our flow
I'm going to use this Nova
act. The
Nova Act is an action
dialect that will translate
the actions that need to be performed
by the browser.
OK, so,
and to click,
to copy, to type, to
take a screenshot.
So here we are starting
the session
and also I want to see what
the browser is doing. Yeah, we can
check. So we're going to use
a DCV SDK
as well
to live stream what is happening
in the browser for us in a local
server using the Port 8000.
And this session is also isolated.
We are going to work with signed
URLs to perform this kind
of access.
There is also the configuration about the
user interface
that we can see in the live browser.
OK,
and the actions that are
going to be
performed.
So we are going to use the playwright
with the Nova act. I need an API
key. Um,
And this is also part of
the layout that we are going to see.
Now we are starting
the viewer session.
Generating the pre-sign
URL,
OK, and it's a temporary access when
we work with pre-sign URL
there is a token that it will be used.
Starting the session of the new
browser using the Amazon.com.
Site, we have also the instructions
over there
and
part of the reasoning. So
I am on the Amazon page, my task
is to search for MacBooks and
extract the details of the first
one. This
is the page.
I thought it was a video.
But this is the page after
the first one has been chosen, who
has been selected. This information,
so from Apple to Midnight
is what we are going to collect. So the
description of the product.
And as we can see here
in the first box,
that's what we collected.
OK. There is also the execution
metrics,
um,
so the prompt that were used, the
number of steps that were executed
in the site.
So first,
We open the site,
type it,
list it and copy
the first item.
OK.
So this is the browser,
er, secure sandbox so we can
perform external actions in web
websites.
One more.
The code interpreter.
We can say that browser and code
interpreter are tools as well.
The code interpreter is to run
your code, so to execute your code
also in an isolated
environment, serverless environment using
a micro VM. This, this is, this
is not going to change,
OK.
We can use
JavaScript,
TypeScript, and Python
for these executions, and there are two
ways to work with that.
The first is the system code
interpreter.
In this case, we are going to use the built-in
libraries and all the built-in configurations
to execute a simple code that
is not required to import
a specific library, so custom libraries,
OK.
So the agent
receives
the instruction.
Decides that it is necessary to call
the code interpreter,
then the session will be mapped
to a specific VM used only
for this case, for this session.
We have also a terminal over there
and a file system. This file
system is ephemeral, so after
the execution, it will be terminated.
And then we have the
result of the execution being returned
to the agent.
But if I need a higher degree
of customization,
there is a custom code interpreter.
So in this case, you are going to package
the requirements
to use in this ecosystem,
OK. You, you package all
the dependencies.
In our
last module, a bunch of modules,
right? But this is good because we can
configure with a higher degree of
granularity,
the observability.
So in the observability,
we have a full enterprise
visualization. It's compatible
to open telemetry, so
you can check your metrics
outside the service if you want,
or you can check inside the cloud watch
as well.
So we can see
tool use, agent actions
using detailed traces, and
there are 3 different visions
that will be provided.
The first vision in the Gen AI
observability dashboard, I'm inside the cloudwatch
system right now.
We can see.
Almost as needed.
We can see how many agents
were instrumentalized so we can
check the metrics.
So just a vision about the agents
and the sessions that are active and the
traces that we collected.
The second vision that we have here.
Is the agent specific metrics,
so how many sessions
per agent,
also the consumer, the tokens,
the latency.
So we can see how the agent is
performing,
but what if, what if we need more granularity?
In this case, we can check a
specific session
that was that ran in
the run time.
OK.
I can check the traces
as well.
Here we only have 3 traces,
so it was a very small
execution.
But there is something new over
here as well.
And this is pretty amazing
because
we were talking about latency,
how the agent is performing,
but what about the quality of
the answers?
Now we can see with agent core
evaluations.
It is still in preview,
but we can check metrics like
accuracy,
helpfulness, faithfulness, harmless,
and stereotyping.
But sometimes these metrics are not enough,
but it's OK.
You can work out with custom metrics,
you have to detail
describe the metric and also
provide a hacking system. It
can be numerical or it can be
also personalized,
OK,
um,
for those who already worked with
Bedrock, um, evaluations,
the interface,
it looks like almost the same.
OK,
but
in this case, where we are working
with the built-in metrics, sorry I
said accuracy, but I, I was
trying to say faithfulness.
But in this case, we are working with
a programmatic evaluation,
OK?
When we are talking about custom
metrics, we are going to use an
LLM as a judge, so
almost the same way that we work
outside Agent core.
So I hope you like it,
our tour on the components
of Agents car,
and the main thing here is
that now we can work with
a higher degree of customization.
We can use whatever model
fits you best. We can use any
framework that your team
or even you, why not? You can work in
your personal project.
It's more user too.
So if you have any questions, I'll be
available next to the stage,
and I hope you enjoy it. We have
a little bit of slides here,
so the developers community,
but today is the last day
for the expo. You have to run
to reach the other hotel, to reach Venetia.
Um
During the event we had several activations
from training certification with the gamification
team, the amazing gamification
team. Also, if you
want to know more about the cloud, you want
to know more about the agents,
you can find this by free
inside the SkillBuilder platform. So
more than 1000 trainings
for you
to get,
to gain more knowledge.
Here we have also training paths
to gain more more experience in
specific areas.
And
I want to see everybody here with certifications.
I'm a golden jacket myself. I want to
see everybody to become a golden jacket
too. And
I want to say thank you so much for
being here in the last session,
and I hope you had an amazing event.